Bag Remake Studio in Shonan, Japan,
repairs designer bags and accessories.
This $800 monogram wallet
is an unmistakable Louis Vuitton staple.
The owner uses it on a daily basis,
and now the lining is deteriorating,
the leather is discolored,
and the paint is peeling on the edges.
One of the studios repairmen will show us
how they restore this wallet
by taking it apart, repainting it,
creating new linings, and
stitching it all back together.
First, the artist takes the bag apart
in order to work on each piece separately.
(soft music)
He uses a seam ripper to
carefully take out the thread.
(soft music)
After he takes off the
outer shell of the wallet,
he uses a sewing awl to take
out the internal threads.
(soft music)
Next, he'll move on to fixing
the severely discolored leather.
He starts by color matching
the brown shade of the wallet.
This shade is made by
combining black, yellow, red,
and white leather paints.
Once he has a perfect match,
he uses a paintbrush
to slowly start coating
the discolored parts of the leather.
He won't touch the signature monogram.
This preserves the
authenticity of the piece.
After years of rubbing against money,
the interior lining needs to be replaced.
The customer requested a nylon lining.
To do this, the repairman
cuts out the new lining
with a sharp knife,
using the exterior of
the wallet as a stencil.
He coats the wallet in glue
and presses the new
lining onto each piece.
Once the piece is dry, they are
ready to come back together.
The artisan sews them slowly,
carefully ensuring each stitch
goes into the exact same hole
as the original.
Once the three main pieces
of the wallet are assembled,
the artisan glues and sews them together.
(soft music)
To finish this repair,
he paints the edges of the
wallet where it's peeling
with an edge coat.
This ensures that all of the
wallet's corners are sealed.
(soft music)
The final step is to
hand rub the whole wallet
with mink oil,
which will prevent the
leather from peeling
or getting discolored
and will extend its
life for years to come.